because of your accent yeah and I want
to ask a question if that's okay because
of your accent and where you're from
yes are you a Republican I'm nothing I'm
an independent registered independent
that's you know I'm so I'm like when it
comes to money Fisk away yeah
conservative me to live when it comes to
yes
pretty pretty open of that pretty
liberal there yeah yeah well you know
it's your libertarian like Joey pretty
much essentially yeah but on I can't and
you know we're not gonna we don't go
into equality we we don't know enough we
know I don't know we don't which is why
I don't really talk about it cuz I don't
like to give an educated I mean I'd
rather give you an educated opinion I
don't have that when it comes to pause I
don't have all the facts and I don't
want to get up there in a high horse and
say well here's how it should be you
know like oh I got that wrong here's why
I bring it up yeah the reason why I
bring it up is because there is you know
you look at my brother Steve for
instance right my brother Steve thinks
that if Texans right are all cowboy hats
and Wrangler jeans and they have Spurs
he doesn't he thinks that is first yeah
if you go to Texas
oh no there's like really everyone looks
this every mess here almost exact
everything but there are people that
think that like you know people with
southern accents thinks other hazards
are from the states that maybe that they
are a trump supporter yeah yeah it's
just based on just the exit where you're
from and dang and I just want to say
that you know I don't care if you are
not I love you regardless because I know
how you feel about me mmm-hmm I know how
you feel about gay people right I know
how you feel about people's rights and
whatnot or and there's there's nothing
oppressive about how you feel about the
world
yeah yeah right you're a good dude I'm
being real you're a good guy I think I
really do believe that I am one of the
best guys guys I agree I agree with you
about me yeah certain but you where do
you live now I live in Hickory North
Carolina I'm moving back my dad had a
stroke a year ago
so but I was out here I got here in 2000
I was here 18 years and you know like I
said earlier career has always done this
have peaks and valleys and lows and
highs and I keep to the point where I
actually miss my family I miss my mom I
miss my dad I miss my brother I miss
everybody and I haven't been there in 18
years I've missed out a lot of [ __ ] so
when I would go home and visit it would
be for Christmas or Thanksgiving
holidays and it would you know it's not
the same and Elway was getting more and
more crowded and more and more shitty my
property value went up at at a townhouse
in Studio City so I thought let me put
this on the market and see what happens
and it was like BAM I'm like ooh that's
good yeah good it's a sign I'm out and I
do nothing has changed for me I still do
the road I'm doing more [ __ ] and chicory
that I've done out here in about five
years because I have time and people who
want to help for no other reason than
they'd like to help me they're my friend
you know I don't have to pull favors
it's different you know out here it's
like you know we all have business
managers agents and all this stuff and
lawyers and you say let's do this thing
like well let me check my calendar I
don't know if I can do that because it
did this thing and it's like it's hard
to get anything done it's funny they say
because I was in San Antonio and the
locals there right they drive me around
they'll pick me up at you mean mm-hmm
noon right take me anywhere there's just
a different kind of energy when it comes
to different towns like these people and
I bet you these kids they like all these
people that grew up with you [ __ ] John
is also you've been on television that
must boggle their [ __ ] minds and in
their heads are like yeah we don't need
my we just want to be a part of it it's
exciting
yes right and that's cool yes yes it is
yeah
so I'm loving it you know I'm actually
living in the house I grew up in right
now my dad is in a skilled nursing
facility he's paralyzed on his left side
which but it's real close to our house
and I'm mom my mom doesn't you know
she's got glaucoma his brittle bones she
doesn't really know how to do a lot of
stuff you know she's not computer savvy
so I'm having to wrangle all the medical
bills all this stuff so I went home to
do that and I'm actually happier now
that I've been
a long time oh my god and I'm so happy
that I had the ability to do that you
know I mean John I want to say this um
my dad died a month ago he had a stroke
ten years ago okay and um he had a major
stroke you know and then he kept having
him and um he struggled for ten years
I saw him maybe five times in that ten
years and um maybe six times and um and
now every single moment of my life is
regret of not spending more time with
him yeah and by you doing this right now
it really just it's it's the only I'm
telling you right now dude it's the only
move yeah secondly this business has
changed
it's change to the point where you don't
necessarily really have to be here
anymore you know I mean I'm I'm I have a
couple of shows that I I haven't and
that Netflix cartoon that they asked me
to and then I'm pitch to thing that
might happen but my point is is that I
think I could have done that if I lived
in Phoenix or Ohio and you could do this
anywhere and yeah but the problem is you
can't get the best guess no that's true